she continued here with Dana Bash
just heard me ask the secretary about
was something that you called on the
Biden Administration to do which is just
to Simply ignore the Court ruling that's
a pretty
stunning position if you think about it
in the in the abstract about the notion
of just ignoring a judge's position so
my question is when this case is
resolved by the Supreme Court
should the administration follow that
decision if that decision ends up
Banning this abortion drug well you know
I I want to take a step back and and dig
into the grounds around ignoring this
preliminary ruling as well there is an
extraordinary amount of precedent for
this there is a term known as agency
non-acquiescence the courts rely on the
legitimacy of their rulings and when
they make a mockery of our system a
mockery of our democracy and a mockery
of our law as the as what we just saw
happen in this mythopristone ruling then
I believe that that the executive branch
and we know that the executive branch
has an enforcement discretion especially
in light of a contradicting ruling
coming out unbelievable that she could
call
the judicial branch making a mockery
what'd you say a mockery of democracy
she is a living walking breathing
mockery of democracy also the way Dana
Bash frames that question she basically
she says it's a pretty stunning position
in the abstract of the notion have you
ever heard anything more perfect from
just like a useless CNN anchor in the
abstract of the notion we don't need the
abstract of the notion you are calling
for one branch of government the
executive branch to not abide by the law
that the judicial branch is passing
that's not the abstract of the notion
it's pretty flat out right in front of
your face I believe at this point AOC by
calling by publicly as a member of
Congress publicly calling for Congress
and in specifically she's calling for
the Biden Administration the executive
branch I don't know if AOC knows this
she was confused about a few a few years
ago we have three branches of government
I'll lay them out for you in just a few
moments
I don't know if she knows this well she
does I know she wasn't sure a few years
ago how many branches of governments
there are but by her as a congress
person in One branch of government
calling on another branch of government
the executive branch to ignore the
decisions of the third branch the
judicial branch I think she's in a
violation of her oath of office I want
you to listen we found it it's only 32
seconds long here is AOC taking her oath
of office being sworn in a couple years
ago and listen listen to the words that
she is swearing to abide by
solemnly swear that you will support and
defend the Constitution of the United
States against all enemies foreign and
domestic
I do that you will bear true faith and
allegiance to the same I do that you
take this obligation freely without any
mental reservation or purpose of evasion
I do and that you will well and
Faithfully discharge the duties of the
office on which you are about to enter
so help you God
congratulations
does a woman who is now telling you that
she's going to have one branch of
government ignore the rulings of another
and and encourage a third branch of
government to go ahead and do that does
she seem like she is protecting her oath
of office to defend the Constitution
[Music]
foreign